don't bring anyone love into this kind
of game we won't play okay so we have
some like classic we play a lot of
usually we have a lot of maybe we've
done the show intro we'll just play it
at the top
okay our ants param we play video and
audio clips from all over the internet
people submit send in like you know
watch it's like just some some content
to basically address okay well we were
hoping that you would maybe take a swing
at is do you think the person involved
in the clip is uh is taking drugs was it
one of you two no it's not okay
or perhaps mentally ill okay perhaps
both what do I think is going on here
why do I think's going on here that's
the segment that's before you have sex
if you want to be horny for two or three
hours like you've never been in your
life and you have access to marijuana to
good weed listen to me
true weed alone can get you really horny
er the normal but it's been on drill
take about 10-12 benadryl before you
want to have your sexual fun with your
partner or whatever you do masturbate
alright what do you think so I'm just
looking at the environment around him
exactly living in Versailles there's
there's there's like he's sitting in an
old sort of angry grandpa recliner and
he looks like a young version of anger
he has some COPD and if you see if you
could see his upper chest
yeah he was using his accessory muscles
to breathe which mean he's got some
chronic lung disease when he takes this
balloon which I imagine his nitrous
oxide I feel like you have Steven Seagal
ability he does his pupils blow if you
can do that and he's also got stair
which means you see the white above the
IRA so this is always when you see the
white you know this this when you see
white above uh-huh that's drugs or
hyperthyroidism about the only two
things will do that with meth being the
probable cause so this is dude with the
tobacco problem because he's got
emphysema
how does 10 to 12 benadryl affect
somebody is that again that makes you
agitated that actually goes the other
way it could it could delay ejaculation
which is what he's talking about yeah I
don't think you really understand this
what he's talking about that's what he's
dog would you recommend somebody taking
I would not recommend it because you get
something called anticholinergic
delirium from that where you really can
get very like delirious you get really
well I'm so the weirdest psychosis I've
seen a botanical anticholinergic
delirium from drug overdoses really I
mean they just get like they just get
why and that could be what wait what's
the anticholinergic side effect
what is Anna : it's it's what
antihistamines do in high dose
cholinergic system display so it's
anticholinergic and it's it's a really
serious side effect I mean you can get
sick so you're gonna get if we would
never want to label anyone alleged I
don't know this guy I don't know about
him but he put this video up and I'm
just analyzing what I send in your I'm
just guessing the opinion there's a
probability that maybe drugs are
involved yeah now will 10 to 12 benadryl
it'll make you agitated which I imagine
to I thought which helps you know well
people
that's what finally oh excuse and and so
you know people think because to banjo
makes me more tired maybe three makes
him four and you get about four and
you're getting into trouble
everything's going on here just from
drugs delusional delusional mental
illness well let's go three daily
analyze the he he was not having our
guys he was pretending diverse yeah she
might have been having an orgasm I don't
know how he got there he might have been
holding a vibrator or something
everything those but first of all we
need to teach them both how to look into
a camera yeah disconcerting with looking
off camera like that and it's not like
they're bringing everybody somewhere
they're way off camera and then they're
in a like a convention center has been
some sort of tantric sex meeting of
switches gross but he looks very happy
that they're there yeah she looks full
of shit basically and they have bullshit
stare yes to me it's just bullshit so
he's just happy to be there he's like
yes yeah he just wants to get laid
that's right you find a path to get laid
and like you hadn't been laid in a while
yeah but that's really what's happening
is she's into it and then he's just
using the long wait so she's delusional
right about this horseshit is it just to
get attention is that is that what we're
doing at the come hug I'm I am guessing
that again it's some sort of weird
gathering you know thing and that wave
is her friend that runs it and she's
just a good example of our friends or
maybe she runs it maybe she's trying to
a commercial that's like a scam
and the other thing is like you draw
people then you get attention yeah
people sign up and then they're like I
keep hugging I'm not coming though
what's going on they're like and you
feel like you're not doing it right you
gotta pay for another another another
conference or you start through the
perfect scam and these are blaming
yourself
pretend that you're coming oh then you
get out of our part of the delusion the
delusion yeah I came it I mean look at
this fucking coming yeah look at his
face he's cracking out and he's like
really you know he's a his neck muscles
contraction is laughing yeah that's
total bullshit it's how little bullshit
yeah it's so yeah yeah we cannot three
of us cannot stand if somebody else is
happy I don't like it either it bothers
me when people can get joyful about
things like that
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
okay I can't wait black guys who love to
fucking fuck good if you're a hot black
guy and you want to fuck me only 95 if
you want to move in you can move in fuck
me
I need hundred you fucked a lot man yeah
we got it rift free food free wrench and
everything else man he has a deal man
hold on jail homeless or you're a thug
wanna come move in a friend come with
you man
free rent you get a lease in a cage fuck
me piss somebody beat me at home you
know you see me when I come over today
try it out try it out man first we go
dark the circles are rest our eyes well
drawn I got swept out of mind and then I
just smell math I can smell that yeah
yeah well the first time we play is
interesting I said you know the funny
thing about this you play this over and
over again oh yeah this is a regular
cliff I'm gonna bring up my
questionnaire
but this I was like you know on some
part of every man's brain that has
wanted to like express these feel like
yeah but this is fuck me but I'm saying
yeah for someone to actually pull out a
camera and going to be this just
disconnected all of it this was somebody
was like severely beaten as a child yeah
it's just all I see is just abused to be
because he's Robbie's reenact
oh he's reenacting the trauma to try to
solve it or whatever whatever our brain
does do that that's interesting what's
with the ball in his head that's well
that's not just a B G there that's just
it's very dark it's not well it he's
shirtless made this sad for me now and
yeah that's why I could never go to
strip clubs and things ya know it's
empowering don't you know it's supposed
to be empowering yeah it is you guys
don't get it so he yeah and my bills and
tried out looks like a kiss let me try
it out he replied only yes fuck man I'm
looking for hardcore guys I mean it want
to do it and I want to deliver it I'm a
hot pot by trash go to your 5 bucks
people just send this into it so that's
nice yeah so grab talking to your fan
[Laughter]
you have to give me one one what do they
call it
101 one deal with the big level football
division one don't give a Division one
varsity which is high school I'll raise
you 100 Jesus City Oh No
I just want to let you know there are at
least two maniacs or at least a few my
Dania her on the shrimp scampi vote and
like they are like getting turned into
lasagna so I didn't need your help
getting a rescue boat over there and and
they they really need your help getting
rescued so could you learn really please
please a what did she say she's talking
to Hitler
she's vlogging to Hitler she's asking
the Fuhrer she's asking him for a rescue
boat two friends were returned to the
scampi happy boat they're turning into
lasagna okay so what Hitler is the guy
she's talking she sings happy birthday
and again I I owe a leader of the third
I always like to look at the environment
well she's a really big fan of that one
direction yeah reminds me of people that
set up you know sort of shrines and yes
the people they're gonna try to murder
them it looks like that kind of thing
yeah and when you give you close your
eyes and delicate Veda listen to her
voice she sounds like she's about six
years old would you which is an
interesting thing that happens in severe
trauma survivors is they their voice
stops and the sex
second maybe we should have a new title
for our and if no will that feel better
now if and if she's not just sort of
being bullshitting she's severely
psychotic will you close your eyes one
second
close your eyes and now what I thought
she said hey healer so severely
psychotic yeah because of the eyes and
and no I don't see any air phaser is
just what she's talking about
oh so disorganized and almost it almost
sounds you know delirious like she's
like well why don't we lighten things up
a little don't ya varsity level or it's
what I see
your thoughts
this not somebody talking but just to
see like what you find funny what you
don't find funny and just your reaction
and then maybe you can
his burner he's gonna zoom right through
there no he's just setting the car up
[Music]
it's funny except I know what that
injury is that's bad that kind of a
question is really bad I mean it's funny
but it's not funny
thank you okay so let us clue you in I
want the debater
I mean crush injuries like that those
are common and they they unclog the low
it's just the worse so what has often
the leg will just split open and unloved
and tire the skin comes off entirely and
depending on how bad the crush is you
know whether or not their kidneys fail
because their muscles crushed and going
into their blood system and how bad the
blood supply is cut off and how much
orthopedic injury there is there yeah
it's just
those are catastrophes I have a people
often die get amputees right and that's
really funny right calm no let's be fair
about something so I've always had and
I've admitted to it I think the way I
deal with with physical injuries as you
laugh I laugh yeah four-thirty it's um I
think it's a red flag to me remember
Sasha and the sub yes Sasha would laugh
in the most horrible situations she was
all of a sudden start giggling yeah
there's nothing she could do about it
she was a great nurse and really
compassionate yes but she had this weird
yeah nervous thing when when things got
really rough and say you know terrible
things started happening she freaked out
like whole laughter but why does my
husband find that clip so funny when
people like thank you because I've
watched the clip several times and we've
had other guests on and I can't laugh
because I had left said how fun unit I
have what's called empathy funny if it
were the Three Stooges the whole problem
is it's one thing that bothers me about
physical slapstick humor is it you you
believe that that's just funny funny
funny mild head injuries fuck people up
for six months yeah yeah what one of
Moe's you know just the fingers in the
eyes yeah of course one of Moe's Blanc's
on the head would be six months of
trouble and
I and it's it is funny when it's the
Three Stooges a Laurel and Hardy when
it's fake
in this case what's funny also is that
his reaction I think also because it's
foreign like that you don't understand
what he's saying yeah you could you can
be there's some distance you can get
from you get distance from it it's a
it's an almost comical reaction yes yes
it was like oh my god that's funny and
there's like oh my god that's really
opinion in a pinning pinning against the
wall I remember when I worked I worked
construction one summer in high school
and this guy had a sone in like morphine
drip pack yeah for his neck that's
bullshit and and I was like worse I go
like why do you have that and he started
telling me like very seriously he was on
this site and they were removing a
bathtub from the third floor and it it
fell out from the lift and it crushed
his neck I laughed so so hard us to love
that well he was just look at me and
then he got he realized that he started
telling me all these other injuries
stories and then he got to the point
where he'd be like I just remembered
you're gonna love this one so he would
do it to entertain me like one time I
was on the site and I broke my arm doing
this and I I've always found that's how
I process how can you bring the guy
around with you all the time keep going
keep the levity go I mean it just it
just I don't know why keep the good
times rolling time you should be coming
to orthopedist you would never stop
laugh laugh all the time
[Music]